chers amis il vient dans le cadre de
notre rubrique soit belle mais ne te
tais pas nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir une future candidate à
l'élection de miss france qui défendra
les couleurs de sa région puisqu'elle
vient d'être élue miss alsace j'ai nommé
mademoiselle anne-lise j'ai nommée miss
alsace grâce à ses pairs
la chanson les feuilles mortes
bon
rapport à ça va vous vous appelez tu
veux ça remonte au oui analyse people et
skate tony chapron sai mauk kham alors
un délit spip vous permettez que je vous
appelle anne-lise envoyant un problème à
travers comme tu veux alice comment
devient ton miss alsace parlez nous un
peu de vous voyez d'accord je te parle
de moi non non de vous oui d'accord oui
alors si tu veux je suis né dans le
périgord
alors à l'âge de 18 ans je suis arrivé
en alsace est à dire il ya six mois
enfin je me suis très bien adapté quoi
prévient il alors bon et alors alors un
jour j'étais dans le bureau avec un
collègue
la collègue de bureau ou non dans le
bureau attaque au lait
et alors je discute avec elle alors il
dit gray analyste tu sais pas quoi ce
que je vais faire je vais faire le
concours de miss assassin ni quoi toi
avec ta gueule tu vas faire le concours
de miss alsace et guti toi et ta gueule
fait beaucoup de vies sas moi je peux le
faire aussi
allah dit si toi tu le fais moi je le
fais pas alors elle l'a pas fait au plan
value venise un petit peu de votre
région de l'alsace
oui par exemple alors écoute ça c'est
vachement important il faut le savoir il
faut que la france entière le sache
l'alsace premièrement et avant tout
c'est vachement beau ensuite
deuxièmement dans l'alsace ya du soleil
dans la journée et à la pluie aussi à le
bruyant ça s'est un peu mélangé quoi à
lorient neige tant l'hiver il ya les
sympas qui embaume qui embellissent la
région quoi il ya les ruisseaux qui
cafouille
la cathédrale qui fait tilt dans des
danses andines temps ça va bien ça va
bien non mais attends temps prévient
suis laissé dire que l'alsace était une
région très vallonné ah oui c'est très
vallonné à ça c'est très bas l'eau n'est
aussi yahia le ballon d'alsace cas le
ballon de guebwiller et je ma belle-mère
ya un ballon d'oxygène et se sont pas
très bien au fond
vous n'avez jamais eu de problèmes avec
vos compatriotes à écoute c'est marrant
tu me pose cette question parce qu'il
m'est arrivé une mésaventure à ses
mésaventures heureuse si tu veux je vais
te raconter une fois
bon alors tu vois je tombe dans l'eau
alors je suis en train de me le noyer
alors comme toutes les personnes qui se
noie bas comme toutes les personnes je
crie au secours au secours
le type hillary vif et est un des cas
trop grande rage et au lieu d'apprendre
le français
c'est très très drôle comment ah oui
comment s'est passé analyse l'élection
de miss alsace écoute physiquement n'y
avait pas de problème j'étais très
nettement au dessus du lot alors pour
l'intellect alors là c'est vachement dur
hein lorsque vous aviez aussi une
épreuve intellectuelle à wisches veut
croire oui et c'était de quel niveau à
peu près au niveau baccalauréat parce
qu'il y avait des deux venait des
charades
vous pourriez nous donner un exemple de
charade
as tu veux la charade bon alors attends
je me rappelle à leur écoute y avait
celle là mon premier c'est un serpent
mon second se trouve sur les toits et
mon tour on le trouve dans un garage en
alsace je ne vois pas bon attends je
vais t'aider
mon premier est un serpent le python mon
second se trouve sur les toits la tuile
bon tout se trouve dans les garages en
alsace le pit en tuiles
je vois qu'on peut vous applaudir pour
avoir
et j'en ai des pires que ça mais je les
garde pour une autre façon ça ne presse
pas et bien si vous voulez vivre
nous allons maintenant terminé
l'interview avec des questions dans
l'ordre ont peut-être plus générale
d'abord une question qui me brûle les
lèvres c'est en a pris comment faites
vous pour garder une ligne si parfaite à
jean-marie à la règle c'est pas
difficile je vois la vierge vers un
régime de choucroute sens elle est
maintenant une lise une question plus
indiscrètes
je t'en prie aussi à nice vous avez déjà
connu le grand frisson
ah non le grand amphi son charme et j'ai
connu le petit chaussettes dans le
village anisé bien avant de vous quitter
nous allons vous souhaiter bonne chance
pour votre future élection oui tout au
moins nous l'espérons à à miss france et
puis peut-être à nice europe et puis
voir peut-être un ami ce monde ou miss
univers a et maintenant qu'allez vous
faire
je vais aller faire la mise de minuit
très très joli mais d'auteur bravo et
permettez moi de vous faire la bise ma
petite analyse camara non mais ho et n'a
pas gardé les cigognes ensemble